[Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  the Italian friends may I may I ask you  may ask you for one moment Milan Catina  please Milan Kathina please can I ask  you for one moment of your attention yes  my prime minister Stephane Laurieann has  gone to football game in Paris so I will  take the opportunity I'm a minister in  the Swedish government to congratulate  Italy Milan and Kojima for this  fantastic year  you know you know we we've DS beat you  up from the football game the World Cup  in football not long ago and now you  beat us in in this Olympic Games I'd say  it's one to one  but congratulate I think you will have a  fantastic game for over 20 20 26 thank  you  [Applause]